MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's more
to Google Kubernetes Engine
cost optimization than
your applications.
There's also your machines.
The underlying virtual
machines are a fundamental part
of GKE costs.
And choosing the right VMs
to run and fit your apps
is critical for balancing
cost and performance.
Today, we'll go over some
tips and best practices
for choosing and customizing
your machine types.
Let's go beyond your GKE bill.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Kubernetes does a lot of the
work to abstract the underlying
infrastructure.
But it's still there.
And how you choose to set it
up can make a big difference
in how your apps run
and how much they cost.
In the last video, we
went over the differences
between understanding
the resources
that your applications
actually use
and what they've been allocated.
With that in mind, you can
also adapt the resources
to best fit your
applications while still
optimizing for costs.
I'll start with a review of
the different machine types
available to GKE and
how to optimize shape
and size, along with binpacking.
After that, I'll go
over preemptible VMs
and finish up with
some suggestions
for cost optimization.
Let's start with some
general machine types.
The N-series machines
were the default
for most general
workloads on Google Cloud.
And they were a
great combination
of powerful and flexible.
Not too long ago,
the E-series or E2
came out as an updated
general purpose machine type.
It's a bit less flexible
than the N-series,
but it's also a bit cheaper.
One example is that
the N-series and E2
series have different sets of
processors that are available.
Here's a table of the
current differences,
but it's a lot of information.
These differences might be
important for your apps,
but they might not be.
E2s have similar
performance to N1s,
but they're optimized for cost.
See if they'll work for your
apps and save some money.
Of course, it's all
about understanding
the details of your app
when making a decision.
There's also a few other
types like compute optimized
and memory optimized.
These are, well, optimized
to help run workloads that
need that extra CPU or memory.
So maybe instead of
spreading your deployments
across a bunch of
general machines,
you could stack them onto
fewer optimized machines.
That's where the shape
of your machines come in.
If your apps have
specific requirements,
you can make sure
that the machines
are shaped to fit your apps.
You're not just limited to
the predefined configurations.
In fact, all of this
is known as binpacking.
It's all about making sure that
you find the most efficient way
to run apps on your machines
and to minimize wasted space.
Kubernetes will try to find
a node to schedule your pods.
And if it can't find
one, it'll add more nodes
according to your node
pool configuration.
Let's take a look at an example.
Here we have two machines, the
E2-standard-16 with 16 vCPUS
and 64 gigs of memory and a
custom E2 with the same vCPUs
but only 16 gigs of memory.
We also have two applications
with different sizes,
and app A has two replicas.
So what happens if
Kubernetes needs to schedule
two more replicas of app B?
The standard has enough
memory but not enough vCPU.
On the custom, there is
enough vCPU for one but not
enough memory for any.
That means Kubernetes
needs to make more nodes.
And since two replicas
of app B couldn't
fit on a new
standard, that means
two more nodes and
even more wasted space.
To help optimize usage, think
about the size of our pods.
They're not all going
to be the same size,
but when we have a general
sense of each application,
we can optimize
nodes around that.
In fact, one strategy
is to use the 2
to the power of n rule,
which involves shaping pods
into vCPU buckets of one, two,
four, eight, 16, and so on.
Now we can have a pretty
predictable idea of how
these will fit on the machines.
And we can use larger
machines to better binpack.
This E2-standard-32 can
hold all of our pods.
And it's much cheaper than
the four previous machines.
There's still some
wasted memory,
but we could use a custom
size to help with that.
Ultimately, you know your apps.
And the more details you
have, the better decisions
you can make on machine types.
Plus, you can always try out
different test environments
and see what happens.
Of course, this is still
a lot to think about when
looking at cost optimization.
The good news is that GKE offers
node auto provisioning, which
automatically figures
out optimal machine sizes
and then dynamically adds and
removes node pools for you.
We'll go over this in much more
detail in the next two videos.
All right, that's enough
about shapes and sizes.
If you want to read
through the full details,
check out the link
in the description.
Let's jump to another potential
way to save major costs,
preemptible VMs.
Typically when
creating a machine,
you can specify if you want
to make it preemptible or not.
And you can pass it along as
you're creating nodes and node
pools in GKE.
So preemptible means the
machines cost a lot less, even
up to 80% less.
But there's a lot to consider
when using preemptibles.
First of all, any instance
can last a maximum
of 24 hours and sometimes less.
They can go away with
really short notice.
So you need to ask yourselves
are my apps fault-tolerant?
That is to say, what would
happen if a machine goes poof?
On top of that, what happens
when multiple machines go poof?
If there's no spare room
to reschedule your app,
it might take some
time before Kubernetes
can bring up enough machines
to run your apps again.
Definitely keep in mind
how your apps handle things
like state, potential
unavailability, and less
than graceful terminations.
There's a great guide
in the description
that goes over how to architect
with these things in mind.
So if you want to
use preemptibles,
make sure that you can
consider how your cluster can
work with your apps.
The cluster
autoscaler, which we'll
talk about the next video, will
actually prefer preemptibles
because it optimizes for cost.
But you'll probably
want a backup node
pool that isn't just using
preemptibles for safety.
Just like the type and
shape of your machines,
you need to know how the full
details of your applications
work in order to
optimize around them.
Now let's flip
this and talk about
super predictable workloads.
If you're planning on keeping
clusters running for years,
you should consider my favorite
committed use discounts.
These are basically
contracts where you sign up
for a one or three
year commitment
on a certain number of
resources, like CPU or memory.
You're committed to
paying for them regardless
of if you actually
end up using them,
but you get a huge
discount in return.
I've got a whole other
video in the description
that goes into more details
about how they work.
For GKE, think about
your resource usage
and how spiky it is.
If it goes up and
down a lot or it
needs to handle
really large spikes
but there's a
minimum amount that's
being used no matter what,
you could make a committed use
discount to make that
baseline much cheaper.
Here's a good example where
some usage is covered,
but there's more
room to save money.
And you can even
consider preemptibles
to handle spiky demand
in a cost-efficient way,
as long as your app
can tolerate it.
For example, if you're
a retail website,
you may need to handle large
spikes for sales or holidays.
On other days, you can
get an idea of what's
required to serve your website.
So there's a pretty
easy baseline
to figure out right there.
Of course, let's not
forget about where
these different
resources actually exist.
Regions have different
prices and they'll
offer different
latencies for your users,
based on where they are.
If your application
isn't latency-sensitive,
you can pick a cheaper region.
But keep in mind that moving
data between separate regions
does have a cost
associated with it.
That also affects your clusters.
So a single-zone cluster
probably makes more sense
for a dev environment.
And a regional cluster
might make more sense
for a production environment.
You can always run different
workloads in different regions,
based on the unique
requirements of your business.
Inter-pod affinity
and anti-affinity
are Kubernetes
configurations that you
can use to help control where
your pods will be scheduled.
You have the flexibility
to really customize
your clusters and machines.
But once again, it comes
down to understanding
your applications.
On the next video, we'll
dive into auto scaling.
Remember to check out the
link in the description
for the full guide on
GKE cost optimization.